all right welcome to Super Tuesday - all
right hopefully if you're a Missouri
resident you went out and voted you know
if you don't vote you can't complain and
even if you do vote you're gonna
complain cuz everybody knows who's gonna
win all right so today it's all about
tactics all right before I won the 1998
Missouri scholastic state championship I
went to a chess camp that summer to get
really good and they only taught me one
thing
study tactics tactics tactics so that's
all you need tactics tactics tactics so
here we go we'll be going over some of
our tactics puzzle this this week
probably about ten of them so you know
if you don't have the answer yet just
pause the tape because we'll be going
through these as fast as we can okay
so let's check out this tactic and this
tactic it is why to move as you notice
he's one away from queening hmm I wonder
if that pawn supposed to be right here
that would have been an easy tactic just
promote the bullet alright alright we
got some uh Steelers fans here today was
a good game you crushed Cincinnati wiped
them out of the playoffs so that was
very exciting yes yes yes it was more
like a Cincinnati meltdown who could
have ever saw that happening alright so
yeah if your bet on the bunglers you get
what you deserve don't like me all right
so all right so in this position it is
white to move and win notice the pawn is
now on the app file darned
and the bishop is blocking the pivotal
f8 queening square
so what could white possibly do oh oh we
got a battle we got a battle between the
two all right well he actually had his
hand up first
Bishop to d4 and unfortunately the
bishop is Hindi cannot retreat to the
queening square its way in chess you
always want to be on the Queen in square
whether it's a rook Knight Bishop you
know just guarding that Queen square you
don't want to be out where you could
potentially get pinned or captured so
okay so that was pretty easy so the game
would have concluded Bishop takes Queen
and then probably in 20 moves if black
was smart he keep his bishop close to
his king so they didn't get forked but
you know whites gonna win all right so
we'll go to the next puzzle here if we
can find it so it's another easy puzzle
all right so it's white to move in this
position notice a lot of tactics are
just you know you've got the rook on the
same line discovered attacks that's why
it's really important all the time to
look what's on the same file the same
rank that's why I really encourage all
my players to do when it's not their
turn instead of calculating oh my god
what if he goes there what if he goes
there and it's like dude you have no
idea what he's gonna play okay so
instead of doing that just look at
what's on like the same line okay my be
pawns in a pin all right you know my
rook is on the same line as that Bishop
that's pretty cool okay his rook is on a
dark square that's pretty cool and I got
a dark square Bishop all right so does
anybody have the answer yet all right
Bishop c7 is the correct answer
I showed this to a kid in LA here just
just attack the rook it doesn't matter
but there's a big difference whether you
go to c5 or c7 if you go to c7 you know
oh my God my rooks attack and my bishop
is tacked when my rook has no way to
attack the bishop so I move there
I take it's like okay no big deal your
bishops in a pin I just got to go over
and attack your rook so you can all just
protect your rook you know and then my
bishop they're okay but if you notice if
you play a Bishop to c5 you could
retreat the rook and guess what the
bishop is protected very good I'll go to
another easy puzzle now this has a
couple couple answers people might be
thinking about so maybe it's a little
trickier can anybody tell me just right
off the bat for white just right off the
bat how many checks does white have in
this position how many he's so good he's
got eight checks okay so you notice
every every Bishop move is a Chuck so
you have a lot of different different
choices okay well which one of the eight
is the best oh we got some hands we got
some dueling hands all right D six
because it's double Chuck is that the
only reason
right yeah you basically want to get the
bishop right okay so you really want to
get that Bishop another try would be
Bishop here check
but then you know he still has a piece
and this dangerous past pun yes so so so
know a lot of times I would just
instantly shout out no no but it might
be good because of this past pawn so
Bishop takes but then I'm gonna say no
because I'm just going to take this pawn
and then when you push
I'm gonna go Bishop the c3 and then
you're out of luck and now you have
absolutely no hope got it
no hope and you want hope so so you're
much rather in this position when he
takes to take back okay even though he
can get out of this now like check for
protect you know at least you still have
hope okay you still have up a minor
piece you're down in exchange but you
got this powerful B pun so you still
have some hope and some life okay does
that make sense
great alright
in this position we'll flip the board
because it's actually black to move once
again in this position black has many
many checks and here's the man of the
hour
thunder robe it's under I just take a
front-row Center right up here yeah
front row center push it up yeah alright
so some drums here so it's a lot of fun
okay we'll try to let Sundaram get this
up this one okay so in this position
it's black to move let me ask you
something Sundaram which piece would you
move to deliver a check in this
the top one it's black to move yeah I
prefer the rift yeah okay
so it so anywhere in the rook goes it's
gonna be check excellent excellent
cuz it's double checkmate right cuz he
can't can't move there can't move there
can't take the rook goes the other guy's
delivering the check excellent
once again my student he wanted to take
the bishop and then it's not good for
him so so gotta be precise so good job
there Sundaram getting the correct
answer so double checks are good as you
saw all right so now we're back to white
to move all right so this one's a little
trickier and if you're not careful
you're gonna get checkmated no but he's
got it right off the bat all right yes
Queen takes pawn check yeah yeah that's
why as silly as all these positions look
checks and captures you've got to
analyze each and every one because Queen
takes pawn Chuck is the correct answer
because after King takes you get this
beautiful night fork and you get to
check them again
and then you can just just win you know
get your king up and you'll be fine okay
but but if you try something cooler
which isn't cooler if you try like I'm
just gonna threaten both the Queen and
checkmate you're out you're out okay
you got a big L okay you're out okay so
got to be careful all right
Sundaram this one's right up your alley
okay in this position it is black to
move
I prefer her to yeah check King moves oh
I got your bishop
uh-oh is you're not gonna get captured
that's the big that's the big trick is
you're not gonna get captured here
anybody see a way to save the night yeah
see if Dini Machuca can figure it out
what more would you play as black here
got any any hope it's a puzzler
that's puzzle how about we just say
forget it you want the Knights so bad
I'll let you have it let's not try it
let's try not to lose this okay
they'll push it
now what start what move do we slam here
that g6 and that's like get out of here
love it alright so here we go
got a few more all right this one's a
real thinker it's a white to move here
no this guy he knows it right away he's
so good so good he's a whiz kid this guy
what's your chest rating 14 that's what
I would have guessed even though I don't
even know who you are okay here we go so
so so what's the solution alright so
this is the position so so as we see
when you do with discovered checks the
most powerful double checks have been
the most powerful discovered checks have
been double checks okay you're you were
you want it you want to say exactly what
he said okay go for it
oh so Knight d6 just doesn't get the job
done unfortunately because you can
retreat here and now you see your honor
checks under them and I got this big big
Queen so when you play Knight to c5
check okay
the King only has one legal move because
he's in double check whenever the King
is a double check the King has to move
right you can't block two checks at once
and you can't can't take two pieces at
once and blah blah blah right also
notice that all of these double checks
have all been discovered checks a double
check has to be a discovered check now
don't even ask me if there can be triple
chips okay so when the King goes the b8
what happens
now as the 1400 said 96 checkmate okay
so unfortunately this rook is in the
Kings way and he can't can't take it as
is this pawn all right in this one would
you rather have it to be white to move
or black to move why is that not
checkmate
rook and block it the tank with the rook
take with the rook and his checkmate
what happens if you would be silly and
take with the Queen now do you have a
checkmate still the 1400 he sees
checkmate mm-hmm what is it Queen to d8
checkmate you see that you're attacking
his flight square all right and so it's
over all right but let's just say darn
we're black in this position are we just
out of luck or he sees it
Queen takes bishop Chuck seems like
suicide seems like suicide c8j he worked
the sea egg made right
he made four white rook c8 mate yep
so when when you're when you're in
desperate situations like oh my god he's
got so many checkmates coming in when
you have to do desperate things and be
crazy sometimes alright we saved the
toughest one for last black the move
pretty tough puzzle pretty tough Danny's
head scratching his head back there
Claudio's just crying he's just occupied
it
can we figure it out Thunder I'm still
thinking he's got a Keith does Keith
have it yet
that's tough it's tough one it's a tough
one it's wait for everybody to try to
figure this one out
oh you got it all right well here comes
Bishop e5 is that were you going to say
Danny sure Bishop e5 Danny was probably
gonna sack the rook and be like I got a
pawn I got your pawn
I got your pawn but problem is I got
these pawns and then you're gonna get
crushed Danny all right so so as
Sundaram suggested Bishop e5 threatens
both the rook and the checkmate hmm so
let's get our night out well I stopped
the checkmate yeah now what
yeah just think to work I like it good
and then hopefully we'll be able to win
this all right so those were the tactic
puzzles now I'm going to show some some
really easy King and pawn and games and
rook and pawn end games okay alright so
we have this position white is going
forward okay the notation is correct
okay so so if I was playing
sundaram I think I could probably win
this game okay as white obviously all
right so let's see so King over which
move should black play here alright man
I'm from Pittsburgh King c7 okay so the
trick to drawing this position is to
always when you have to move backwards
right I always move to the queening file
got it whenever you have to move
backwards just stay on the queening file
and you'll have no problems right now
you don't have to move backwards right
anybody forcing you to move backwards no
so don't move backwards okay never let
up your ground if you move backwards
he's gonna take the opposition and crush
okay got it
so so in this position okay
so you don't want to let your ground up
so what do you think you want to do you
want to seize the opposition so you want
to go the d7 okay and then if Jack where
do you think we want to go c7 okay c7
but I get you so okay we're on c7 so now
we have a position that we've seen
before except the pawns a little bit
closer right so what move should we make
here
yes 1400 Kings c8 staying on the
queening file and now it's like hmm I
think I'm gonna go the other way now
maybe you don't know what to do so we
only have two legal moves here do we
want to go to be a or d8 behave yeah
that's the place to be and now we're
gonna try to trick you instead of
checking you I'm just gonna just come
down here now what move do we want to
make how about we get close to the pawn
as possible okay and then King moves now
it's tricky tricky we have not seen this
type of position before deception we
just lost the game we just lost the game
because cuz yeah king b6 I knew I knew I
had confidence I would beat you all
right so so you see how how if we play
king b6
now you're not behind me blocking me
anymore
now we're level and now you have no
place to go you can go over here then
I'm coming up you can go and
check and then Queen and I win all right
moment of truth Sundaram where do you
want to go because if we go forward we
lose we never want to go all right and
now as we know we never want to go
forward in these well that's not
necessarily true
we are we never want to be on the same
rank as the pawn we either want to be
one rank in front of it like threatening
it or just one behind it and when we
have to go to ranks behind it which
square do we want to be on the same
square as the queening file so what's
that magic square then be eight be eight
and then it's over and then I can push
an arrow so if we women so let me ask
you this question Sundaram which file is
the queening file that's the first thing
you should ask yourself when you have
these pawn and games you should say hmmm
which file is the pawn on c5 okay so you
always will know see file and then the C
file is the queening file okay so so now
you know where whenever you retreat
where do you want to go which [ __ ] the
c8 right the C file alright and then I
come up and now where do we want to go
we can go to b8 which is close to the
king or d8 which is away from the king
b8 excellent and then when I come back
here to c5 where do we want to go
yes he's happened yeah thank you and now
you go this way now we have to retreat
so where do we want to go see eight
excellent and now we go up where do we
want to go be eight or DEA which one be
eight away from the king no but you said
be eight and you see how be eight is
away from the king
okay all right all right so now I'm
going away from you you want to follow
me or do you want to attack the pawn
yeah because if we if we go too far away
oh so good yeah get going good get close
to the pawn as possible right and now
now we go back to c8 right and he comes
up d8 right and now it gives us a big
check
so where do we want to go here at moment
of truth
CA excellent and so now he's like oh man
if I go to see c6 this is gonna be a
stalemate right so he's got one last
trick he goes to e7 and this is a
legitimate trick here take the pawn good
because if you don't take the pawn you
lose so you always have that one last
trick up their sleeve okay all right so
let's let's see another so so just want
to do a quick recap here all right so if
we start with this position if it's
black the move whenever we retreat to
the queening square or if so if we have
disposition we retreat to the Queen
square goes here go into opposition
check go back to the Queen and square
still okay cool all right well I think
we've learned enough for today thank you
very much